did your mom make you take classes or
anything like you know like sports or
music or anything well this was
something that a lot of kids did at this
school I grew up at in Connecticut
um there's like a cotillion like
ballroom dancing you definitely weren't
poor
because nope no poor people even know
what Cotillion is like like I still
don't
you're not wrong Kelly but uh but it was
uh it wasn't my thing just to let you
know like my I wasn't into it but it was
the only thing that boys and girls could
do in that town together it was I don't
know some guys are you in the movie
Footloose like like wait what it was uh
no no this was a pro dance thing but but
sadly it was just like ballroom dancing
and it was cool it was not cool but it
was uh it was again I'd seen in these
movies I watched growing up so I thought
that'll be cool and then I was so bad at
it I kind of there was a kid who um on
National Television I will call Frank
but that's not his name and you know who
you are Frank who like made fun of me a
lot like because because I didn't get
the ballroom dancing steps right or
whatever I still think I was cooler than
him but he was technically much more
popular than I was but then uh when I
started act I guess I did one movie and
then my second film was uh Mona Lisa
Smile if anyone remembers that oh my
gosh I love that one and I have to dance
with Julia Roberts in this movie damn
and so they said like were you like
before filming starts I was already just
terrified to meet her they're like will
you come do a ballroom dancing class
with Julia Roberts and I was like this
is my shot
I think everything I learned in that too
oh here we are uh dancing
it's me and my uh
yeah yeah I was so scared I stepped on
her toes like a couple times and she was
very cool about it and then uh when we
did it on the day the whole cast was
also dancing on the dance floor and
again I won't use his name but I told
her this story and Julie Roberts came to
me at the end after the scene and she
high-fived me and she goes that was for
Frank and I was like
ah we can't stand Frank whoever you are
Frank you know who you are yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]